a setback in the battle against the
coronavirus
cases of re-infection are emerging in
hong kong
the united states and europe
they suggest immunity from the disease
does not necessarily last long the world
health organization is calling for more
studies
concrete answers are vital in developing
a vaccine
that is if we ever get one
[Music]
so much for herd immunity or full
immunity and what about natural
immunity so many questions which we'll
get to in a moment with an expert
first the world's first genetically
verified case of someone being
reinfected with covert 19 and what that
could mean for the pandemic
as the coronavirus pandemic took hold
scientists knew
a vaccine would be the best protection
against the virus
but there was still the hope that those
recovering from infections would be
immune
as is the case with viruses like
smallpox or polio
when a 33 year old man in hong kong
tested positive for a second time
those hopes were ruined
some people might ask will you be immune
to the virus forever after you recover
there wasn't a clear answer before but
now it's certain
after your first infection there's
always a chance you'll get infected
again
in their research paper the team at the
university of hong kong
says the second infection was a
different strain of the virus
and that the patient was asymptomatic
the study examines how often people
who've had covert 19
are immune to new infections and for how
long
these questions have implications for
vaccine development
and decisions about returning to work
school and social activities
as many countries in europe and around
the world went into lockdown to slow the
spread
sweden went against the tide opting not
to confine its population
schools and restaurants remained open in
the hope that infected people would
become immune
thus allowing them to continue their
lives as normal and ultimately slowing
the spread of the virus
i think swedish people are
taking big responsibilities so if you're
sick we stay at home
and if we're not we can be outside
sweden's infection rate and deaths per
million
were soon among the worst in europe
and yet testing showed the country still
fell a long way
short of the estimated 90 percent which
would create herd immunity
nor is the rest of the world anywhere
close to that
the who says that until the world has
readily available vaccines
the virus will continue to inflict
significant changes on our lives
now as a planet as a global population
we are nowhere close
to the levels of immunity required to
stop this disease transmitting
and we need to focus on what we can
actually do now to suppress
transmission and not live in hope of
heard immunity been our salvation
right now that is not a solution uh and
it's not a solution we should be looking
to
for for our salvation and the immunity
picture is looking increasingly
complicated
in the southern german town of bad
feinbach a study by germany's robert
koch institute
found that 40 of participants who had
tested positive for the coronavirus
before the study began
no longer had immunoglobin g antibodies
the most common type of antibody
we know from other studies that a
proportion of people proven to have been
infected with sars cove 2
show no antibodies after a certain
amount of time
but this doesn't necessarily mean that
they don't have immunity to sars cove
too
the robert koch institute is now
conducting several regional studies
and plans to start a country-wide
antibody study at the end of september
as researchers toil to bring vaccines to
the world
questions are looming about whether it's
feasible to create a vaccine
that would actually work for a lifetime
well let's go over to thomas kamrat he's
director of the institute for immunology
yina thomas what are the chances
of getting re-infected
the chance seems to be real but slim
there are several case reports from
different countries on people who have
recovered from covet 19 and then fell
sick again there's a series of eight
patients from china and single reports
from hong kong and some
european countries so it seems to be
possible
but you're saying rare what about
um other cases that haven't been
uncovered and and
more studies that have to be done
according to the world health
organization i mean could this be the
tip of the iceberg
probably not because from we know a
little bit about
the immunity against covet 19 by now
people usually develop
antibody responses which are protective
people usually develop
responses by t cells which are
protective but we do know that in some
people
these responses may be short-lived so
that would be
a possibility to explain the fact that
some people can become reinfected after
will but most people
should have protective immunity for some
time after their infection with coward
19 with ceroscope too
but but what about full immunity i mean
does that exist when it comes to covet
19.
what do you mean by full immunity that
once infected you can never get infected
again in your life
is that what you mean exactly well
that's true
that's too early to say because we only
know this infection since a little bit
more than half a year
so thus far the vast majority of the
symptomatic patients and and the
asymptomatic that have been investigated
uh have not fallen sick again
but we do not know if the immunity
against the virus will last for a year
or for two years or for many years
experience from other coronaviruses
including the zas coronavirus shows that
the immune responses wane after some
time so for those
immune responses antibody responses were
no longer detectable after six
years in most of the people so we do not
expect
lifelong immunity after an episode of
covet 19 probably
and the big question what about
developing vaccines or drugs to treat
a covert infection doesn't doesn't
success depend on knowing exactly how
immunity against the disease works
well vaccines have often been developed
quite empirically and there's a lot of
vaccines promising vaccines in
in the pipeline we do know a little on
protective immunity you're absolutely
right we we need to know much more but
thus far it seems that the vaccines that
have been tested
are inducing the right responses and
probably or possibly we will have to be
content with
uh less than the normal success so maybe
a vaccine would not induce
a lifelong immunity or not inducing
immunity that lasts for 10 years or so
but even if it lasted
for two or three years i think it would
be a great success and even if it would
just prevent
the severe clinical courses if it would
switch a clinical a severe clinical
course to a mild infection i think that
would be a huge success already given
the current situation
so could it mean getting immunized
getting a
like a flu shot every year basically
we don't know if it would be every year
every other year or every three years or
so but that could be the case it would
be
slightly different from flu because flu
you need a new shot every year because
the virus changes so rapidly
that does not seem to be the case with
the coronavirus in the
with the saskof2 if one would have to
immunize more frequently it would
probably be because the immune response
a memory wanes against
the virus and therefore it needs to be
refreshed that that's a possibility that
needs to be explored
thomas cameron from the institute for
immunology indiana thank you very much
thank you very much have a nice day for
a look at some other aspects concerning
the coronavirus it's over to our science
correspondent
derek williams with your questions
we've heard about the underlying
diseases and conditions that can
influence the severity
of covid19 outcomes but does viral load
also affect severity when i began
looking into this i quickly realized
that there's still no a clear answer to
this question
partly because the amount of virus in a
patient's body
changes from day to day as
the disease progresses we know from
other diseases that
that high viral loads are are linked
to infectiousness um but do they also
affect disease severity in covet 19
well the information coming out of the
studies
is kind of conflicting um a recent a
fairly large scale one for example
found a clear link between mortality
and and high viral load in in
hospitalized patients
and even suggested it could be used as a
tool
for stratifying patient risk but other
studies that have measured
viral loads in for example children who
had
very mild forms of the disease found
they were generally carrying
even more virus than adults who develop
severe forms of the disease
and then there are the studies showing
that that asymptomatic or
pre-symptomatic adults
can also have very heavy viral loads
so so after hours of reading this is how
i would interpret the data because kids
and asymptomatic adults can have lots of
stars
too in their bodies but no symptoms
high viral loads don't seem to be a
reliable
indicator of disease severity until
you land in the hospital with a severe
case
at that point it does become an
indicator of outcome severity um
what we still don't know is whether high
viral load is actually
causing the disease to get worse for
those patients in the hospital
or if it's an effect but at least in
those who are hospitalized
the two are associated in some way
[Music]
well over 38 000 people turned out to
protest against germany's coronavirus
measures on the weekend
there were multiple arrests after
clashes with police
they say right-wing extremists co-opted
the demonstration
over 9 000 people have died from the
virus in germany
still protesters believe the danger is
overblown
personally i don't believe that there's
a pandemic i do think the disease exists
but not a pandemic
well according to the new definition of
a pandemic it's a pandemic
but that has to do with how much it's
spread and not with how dangerous it is
finally medical staff are among those
most at risk of getting the coronavirus
but a hospital in mexico city has taken
on a new employee
with complete immunity to covert 19. la
luchi
robotina goes from room to room
providing support to patients
with the robot's help they can talk to
relatives via video call or to the
hospital psychologist
feelings of isolation are a big problem
for covert sufferers and this
is where the robot comes in
you